joe biden and kamala harris yes the
democratic ticket is finally set
but you know who's already won snl alum
maya rudolph
i'm just gonna have fun and see if i can
get some viral moments
mama needs a gift
gonna tell my kids this was michelle
obama
maya was actually talking live on a
panel with ew when the news broke about
kamala's vp nomination
a reaction it's like the gift that keeps
on giving but i'm as surprised as you
are guys
that's um that's spicy
meyer returned three times to snl to
play senator harris
when she was running for president i'm
also america's
cool aunt and she's up for an emmy for
the role
i love going to the show any excuse i
can get i love i just didn't
really anticipate traveling during a
pandemic
um but if there's anyone that can work
it out i'm sure lauren
has some sort of um invisible helicopter
that can get me there
and what about jason sedakis joe biden
if november goes vice president biden's
way could you have kind of a full-time
gig on snl coming back
we'll we'll see how that all how that
all shakes out but yeah i understand the
responsibility of
popping in those giant fake teeth that i
wear when i play him
uh and i try to be responsible with that
with that power well i can't wait to see
if we can get some
maybe virtual debates leading up to it
with you and alex
wrong overruled but is alec baldwin
ready to resign as trump
i'm completely innocent last year he
told the hollywood reporter
i can't do it any longer alec explained
he's
over 60 with four kids five and under
and quote
there's a lot of people who can play
trump when alec won an emmy for the role
he said
the love from trump's detractors was
overwhelming
they walk up to me and they slap me on
the back all day long and say thank you
thank you thank you for helping us to
in some small way manage that pain
you